après 23 ans près d'un quart de siècle à
la tête de fondaction léopold beaulieu
tire sa révérence il sera bientôt
remplacé le processus de sélection est
en cours léopold beaulieu est notre
invité ce soit avant soit monsieur
beaulieu bonsoir qu'est ce qui vous
anime qu'est ce qui vous pousse comme ça
à laisser votre place à la tête de
fondaction d'abord c'est ont fait
passagers 73 en beauce est jeune oui
merci si vous fournissez 2,78 à monsieur
bloomberg 67 ans ne feront pas avancer
ça mais bon mon épouse de la retraite
alors bon jeu parce que et quand on fait
ça quand on s'y prépare quand on y pense
on le fait quand l'organisation est en
bon état
or fondaction est en excellente
situation
sa croissance est très importante le il
ya de l'argent fondaction investit dans
1200 entreprises soit à travers des
fonds spécialisés soit directement et
c'est fondation contribue au maintien
mais création d'emplois l'an dernier de
39 1500 emplois bon alors voilà c'est ça
et il ya cette reconnaissance aussi
quitté la croissance de fondaction comme
justement très engagé le gouvernement le
reconnaît très engagé développement
durable et avec la croissance de
fondaction ça n'a pas été une dilution
de cette intuition départ ça a été un
approfondissement
ça a été une expertise qui s'est
accentuée qui c'est qui s'est constituée
pic s'est accentuée et qui aujourd'hui
est reconnue vous êtes le fondateur de
fonderie gelé fondées oui vous l'avez
fondé au milieu des années 90 comme vous
avez participé à la fondation de la
caisse d'économie solidaire au début des
années 60 vrai pour fonds d'actions de
quoi êtes vous le plus fier ce dont je
suis le plus fier c'est de ce que je
viens de dire on est reparti avec un
journal en dessous du broc est elle ou
gilles francoeur un article j'allais à
genève à l'oit et et c'est l annonce du
rapport brundtland
oui et moi pour moi c'était jeu c'était
une confirmation de conviction que
j'avais déjà que l'on doit pas séparer
les ne pas regarder en silo l'économie
d'un côté l'environnement de l'autre la
société le social les alors et puis une
place aussi pour les entreprises
d'économie sociale dans une économie
plurielle une sauce et ça c'est les
sociétés qui s'en sortent le mieux là où
il ya de l'état là où il ya bien sûr du
capital actions mais aussi des
entreprises d'économie sociale
coopératives mutuelles au bien-être
parce que beaucoup de capital actions
maintenant la fond'action si je me
trompe à 30% des investissements c'est
de l'économie sociale c'est ça et 70%
ces deux sociétés capital-actions faire
ton fondaction a évolué et changé on a
comparé changé est née sur ce registre
là alors et cette disponibilité aux
entreprises d'économie sociale ben quand
vous parlez de prendre pour ça bon alors
il ya certains certains observateurs qui
disent que l'économie sociale s'apaise
pour à peu près 10% du pib
oui alors donc les bottines suivent les
babines comme on dit des fois alors oui
mais c'est une disponibilité à l'endroit
des entreprises qui est des
entrepreneurs qui ont fait fait brelan
de rendre leur entreprise cohérente avec
une vision de société
cela dit est ce qu'on doit repenser
l'enjeu des crédits d'impôts avec les
fonds de travailleurs le fonds ftq et
fondaction est ce que on devrait
commencer à réfléchir à cela
c'est vrai que c'est intéressant sur le
plan du rendement mais est-ce que
fondaction doit encore s'appuyer en
quelque sorte sur cette scène de crime
oui parce que oui c'est fondaction a
besoin de continuer à s'appuyer sur
cette cible de crédit parce que la
taille notamment
vous savez c'est beaucoup de bière dans
un sous-sol 2 milliards 2.2 milliards
oui mais dans pour une institution
financière qui porte ce projet c'est
vrai que fondaction et le fonds
d'investissement le fonds de
développement de plus importants engagés
en développement durable
bon c'est vrai mais il faut il faut il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin et c'est
dans cette direction que fondaction
poursuit sa démarche
votre vie a été voué à la protection des
travailleurs au syndicalisme parce que
vous avez été associé bien sûr à la csn
avec avec fondaction à l'épargné
également des québécois est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut aussi réfléchir à la
place des syndicats par exemple dans la
société c'est le rapport au travail et
il ya là une pertinente qui continuent
d'être là et puis la répartition de la
richesse créée entre le travail et le
capital et bain il ya là quelque chose
qui est un enjeu qui vaut qui demeure
moi je veux continuer et puis avec le
développement du numérique de
l'intelligence artificielle
il ya une proportion de la mettre pour
une riche pour une productivité très
accrue ben il ya une formation en cours
d'emploi
il ya des enjeux fondamentaux pour être
capable d'avoir une société où on
s'occupe aussi des dollar et partent de
la répartition et des inégalités faire
en sorte que les enjeux du développement
le développement durable ça inclut des
enjeux économiques et financiers les
enjeux sociaux on parle d'une égalité on
parle de bon et puis l'impact sur
l'environnement de l'activité
et c'est absolument nécessaire d'avoir
cette vision plus globale qui ce dont je
suis le plus fier c'est que ça a
caractérisé l'intuition de départ de
fondaction oui et s'approfondit et fier
de l'être et c'est la trajectoire qui se
prononce est ce qu'on va prolonger et je
pose la même question parce qu'on la
pose dans le dossier de la caisse de
dépôt jusqu'à la nomination d'une femme
est ce qu'une femme pourrait succéder à
alain paul beaulieu jeu je ma réponse à
ça elle est la suivante il faut trouver
la personne la mieux appropriée pour
prendre la suite et prolonger la
trajectoire de l'organisation que ce
soit un homme que ce soit une femme qui
soit quelqu'un qui vienne l'inter nous
quelqu'un qui vient de l'externe
ce qu'il faut c'est arrivé à trouver
la personne appropriée c'est ce qui
compte et moi je suis disponible jusque
là je reste en poste
oui et demi pour la transition pour la
suite pour la transition si cette
personne trouve pertinent que je
collabore avec elle me dira ce qu'elle
attend de moi merci monsieur beaulieu
merci beaucoup merci